you guys ready it all started with a
marshmallow concert
let's go let's go let's go
it was an interactive virtual event that
took place within the popular video game
fortnite and it was the first of its
kind within the metaverse
metaverse the word that's been popping
up everywhere recently is a virtual
community and within that community
people can play games work or in this
case attend a concert fortnite's concert
was a huge success
nearly 11 million people live streamed
the event and today that number is north
of 60 million on youtube
and that was just the beginning
a little over a year later it was
announced that rapper travis scott would
venture into the virtual concert space
and just like marshmallows it was a
massive success
travis scott's show proved how
profitable these virtual concerts could
be and just like real-life concerts
there's merchandise to be sold lots of
it in addition to the physical merch
players can also purchase skins and
emotes which are dance moves and other
actions your character can perform
within the game
and all that can add up scott reportedly
grossed 20 million dollars from his
fortnight collaboration including
merchandise sales that's a huge number
considering his entire astro world tour
from the year before grossed 53.5
million dollars
following fortnite's success other
companies like pokemon have followed
suit creating a virtual concert for its
25th anniversary with post malone in
february
[Music]
and in august ariana grande hosted a
virtual concert and is reportedly set to
make the same amount as travis scott
and now justin bieber is the latest pop
star to announce a concert in the
metaverse space partnering with virtual
entertainment company wave
waves virtual concerts will be performed
live unlike fortnite shows and people
will be able to send emotes that the
performer can see in real time
it will be interesting to watch the
evolution of these virtual concerts and
the revenue they generate for the
companies and the artists that partner
with them